gang the boys are on the road with that
stay trashy tour coming to a town near
you grab the squad come out and see us
little stand-up comedy plus we played a
little ayg with the crowd it's a good
good time yeah gang uh June 14th we're
gonna be at hilarities in Cleveland June
15th we're going to be at the Funny Bone
in Columbus then obviously we have New
Jersey the Vogel theater the second show
added for that those tickets are going
get them before they're gone uh we'll be
adding more shows get your tickets are
you garbage.com love you yeah welcome so
another exciting edition of are you
garbage
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage isn't it it's that
little show we sit down to your favorite
comedians and we find out the group to
be classy yeah or if they're just a big
old piece of trash trash I'm your host
Dave Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're out back here at hoodies and
the new edition baby getting ready for
summer she's upstairs in her room
blasting Gwar
must have had a rough day she's letting
it out okay really just
coming through man I'm surprised you
know who Gore is of course what do you
mean I know what's going on covered in
blood I know what the kids are doing out
there sure and today of course my
co-host is coming at you from across the
table he is the CEO of Ru garbage but as
the summer starts to roll around he is
known as Mr Neptune down there on the
boards the kid likes the Sam's Pizza
shout out to Wildwood and some
medium-sized waves to do a little body
surfing give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan what up gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure your rate
review subscribe over there on the old
iTunes uh full video available on
YouTube check that out and as you know
those numbers are almost forgot it there
you ain't lying uh then obviously the
greatest website uh one of the greatest
one of the two greatest websites of all
time I'm gonna change it www.ru
garbage.com gang that's now the new best
website in the world wow you're crazy
well we sold nine t-shirts
guys obviously I'm joking it's
patreon.com Sam yam I'm sorry I don't
care how many Koozies you got over here
shout out to patreon.com
check it out uh we got a whole [__] ton
of content over there we have all the
bonus vids we throw in Vlogs plus if you
sign up at the 10 level you get two
episodes two bonus episodes a week what
are we doing over here it's a good time
it's a party having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man got the long hair it's got the
cut off jean shorts no socks the
interrogation like cooking where were
you on the night of the 13th
okay you got a bad hit of Molly over
here take that off give it up for T-Bone
discrepancies Toby McMullen everybody
what's up dudes hey buddy yeah my outfit
stinks with holy shirt with the fishes
you look like the ocean buddy what are
we doing swinging a Miss on top two on
two down two how do we cut that McMullen
hit by a pitch it looks like [__]
Mullen was just thrown out of the league
somebody turned up Toby's mustache huh I
got thrown by the intro you're taking
shots what are we doing I'm not taking
shots I'm trying I'm trying to figure
out I write on stage
I'm trying to figure out a new one for
you there are a bunch of times where
you're going uh you know it's the summer
upstairs and I'm going I don't think he
has it hoodie I don't I got nothing I'm
going I'm looking I can see the wheels
spinning like that's when the big man
does his best work I'm like Eminem off
the Dome that's not what he's known for
I do right on the bus
a Bang Bus
I have something controversial
to discuss does it have to do with food
it does sure of course you're not live a
life worth combination that's what they
talk about of course listen this isn't
anything that I'm gonna get involved in
now so let's go into that
with that understanding
but I really missed out on this okay you
know I'm trying to tighten it up I'm
eating right all that kind of stuff
but there's options to this where it
wouldn't be that bad but it's the big
thing that's going around now
everybody's doing it everyone's talking
about it everyone's talking about it
it's they're taking sandwiches
all right they're taking like turkey ham
lettuce tomato pickles
onions all that stuff they're throwing
some mayo or some mustard or however you
want to do it and they're chopping it up
and they're putting that inside a
sandwich
that's that's all I wanted my whole life
you could have done that I know I can't
believe I never thought of it what's the
best part of anything the end then that
when you get down to the salad and
everything's all mixed in together all
that lettuce is gone and it's all the
stuff all just chopped up and delicious
and it's been mixed together it's
already it's already chewed is what
you're looking for somebody somebody cut
out the middleman and chew it for you
hey I can't be doing all this biting and
chilling around here I gotta get this in
my gulled stats someone chew it up
pre-chooed Sammy's but I'm big on the
flavor combinations to everything it's
about to really blow up it's about to be
the next chopped cheese and I know
that's could you read that in fact guy
quarterly what are you talking about you
guys have no idea what I'm talking about
I have no idea what you're talking about
I feel like I've mentioned it to you
months ago when it was when it was but
it was still in the underground it was
still sizzling after after the after the
demo tape dropped I've started hearing
buzzing buzzing the streets and
Overeaters Anonymous we got into it I'm
not gonna lie to you I'm still thinking
about bombing in the intro
don't worry about it
um play
I mean this is a kooky one I didn't I
don't know
what's in here by the way
for being honest
[Applause]
really
whoa It's a real tell all episode right
here that's what I'm talking about
I can't do it it was like The Tell-Tale
Heart I can smell over me you're free
balling over there sure am wow yeah it
was a yeah this is this is a wild day
we're in you're sure David short in a
very long time
two three weeks
it's good for you man but when that
happens and you're so luckily you clean
yourself up in there no I just figured
I'll figure it out when I get home yeah
I clean myself up there you little bird
right here Brian's gonna have to repaint
in there
um I that's just when that happens
the Panic that sets in and I'm not you
know I'm not one I'm not I'm not big on
body humor you know what of course uh
classy program but there's a certain set
of panic that sets in when that happens
when you're out not at your house and
luckily I'm in my I'm in my I'm in my
aunt's house right now so is that okay
you know what I mean I gotta say this
I've I've grown out of that I've moved
past it what I'm steady as a cucumber
calm yeah well what happened was I it
hasn't happened in years but I had a
smoothie this morning and that I mean
I'm the [__] spinach must have been
better mixed in with that hot honey
chicken boy
that was in the Easy Pass yeah dude you
can't you can't [__] Zig and zag like
that you gotta pick a lane for a day
your body don't know what's going on
I'm upside down this guy's doing pretty
what the [__] and you drop that in there
this guy
can't mix that I didn't have a choice of
a single father
I'm working hard over here
yeah I don't know man I am what I am or
I'm an open book have at it don't act
like I'm the only guy who's ever had an
accident so no that happened to me this
weekend don't be silly you just said
you're steady no it doesn't it doesn't
bother me Oh I thought you meant you're
in such control of your body
that he shits his he shits himself and
doesn't break stride yeah you're like
Leo in The Departed my hand doesn't
that's what I'm saying I can sit with
full-blown Poopers it doesn't matter
I handle the situation I play a real
cool
um
well
physically
I have a little bit more protection
let's say it doesn't always reach the
fabric no
no the volcano doesn't always rise to
the crust
I mean what what are we doing here
this is not reading some poetry or
something we got class this up a little
bit uh yeah
um sure she's gonna [__] dumper on
you
laughs
get the Shamrock got the Shamrock Shake
back there pressed hams in those in that
set of sheets you got by the way I just
throw out a 50 pair of underwear
but it's like you're cleaning up a
murder scene dude you're like you're
inspecting everything I got bleach out
sure it's you're because you don't want
to get caught because it doesn't matter
but you're going hey you're if it
happens at work or something I happened
to work one time when I was bagging
groceries at Acme that's not something
you can be like hey I gotta go home I
[__] no it happened to me one time when
I was driving and I wore scrubs because
we delivered medical equipment to
doctor's office you're a drug dealer
I swear to God I'm a doctor I'm a doctor
used to be an anesthesiologist and yeah
that's a bad situation dude if it gets
through the jeans it didn't even you
gotta move home oh yeah you gotta pack
it up so pack it up and go home no it
didn't even uh
yeah it was it was a I was more
impressed that you were uh
that you're free balling it right now I
didn't I mean it's not like I I didn't
have enough I didn't have an option at
the new studio I would like to have a
set of fresh gear in case that ever
happened I keep pairs stashed around the
city like if I had luckily I don't have
a spot if I had spots tonight and I had
to go free ball it or something there's
nothing I did I'm telling you I never
wore underwear when I was like
attractive I never wore underwear when
was that college two weeks ago
I'm kidding of course when I was thin
yeah I never wore underwear yeah you
should at this age yo yeah College I
didn't wear underwear either really
really and wear pants I was
hanging brain
um but yeah I didn't wear underwear that
much no but as you get older it feels
good doctor things are looser Burt
Reynolds things are loose yeah you do
feel like if you feel like a porn stuff
I'm about to show my [__] show my
little hips all get a settle over I'm
gonna fold these down one roll
act like I'm Britney Spears out here
throw out these mom jeans let's get some
Hip Huggers
um yeah no I as you get older especially
you know hygienic hygiene yeah you got
it you just gotta do it yeah they arrest
me if I did it now what are you nuts
[Music]
yeah it's tough It Ain't Easy
what do you think about that sandwich
what could that be a thing
I think it's really
it's perfect what like a chopped up
sandwich yeah that's what I always
wanted I just didn't realize it
yeah I don't go back now that nice
semolina bread
mm-hmm yeah it seems like you're really
over it what are you gonna do I didn't
know these were fish by the way
that's why I didn't get I would have
eaten them weeks ago
uh yeah I don't know it's uh
you have that thing where like you'll
watch Food Instagram and stuff when
you're hungry I don't I don't like I
don't lust over food the algorithm it's
because of the what you're putting into
it when you Google chicken farm 38 times
it gets a reader
you don't have to be [__] Zuckerberg
to figure that out okay
bastards yeah they got you dead the
rights now you know what I wanted to ask
you
have you seen these pierogies don't get
me started Cheesesteak pierogi shout out
Aunt Carol when did all right I was in
an Uber the other day and I don't
remember remember this when I was a kid
I remember it starting maybe 10 15 no 15
20 years ago
um but now it's like you can't even you
can't even roll the window down when did
the helicopter start
it's crazy two windows in the back I get
it diamonds in an Uber there cracked my
window yeah can you see what causes that
is going on I don't know I do understand
what you mean I remember as a kid the
first time it happened
those are my Dad's Jeep shout out I like
that almost drove off a cliff it was
like someone you think somebody about
Huey was coming in went off a flashbang
in the car the way he freaked the [__]
out dude uh crazy but it is more
prominent than before and I don't know
why we used to go down that Highway with
all four windows down because the AC
didn't work but I think is it one it's
like sometimes when it's one it's dude
it's one it's like It's gotta be let me
guess let me it's got to be some sort of
negative pressure versus positive
pressure like there's a negative
pressure inside so the air is pretty
shits his pants relax
Johnny know on these
I'm like Marky Mark over this guy
I'm supposed to take home orders from a
guy who's got his balls on his jeans
yes the guy who writes the checks around
here
I'm out of the bathroom and immediately
start [__] barking orders to look
which I respect yeah just touching the
zipper I have to [__] zipper button
Maybe
still plenty of room in there
that was a quick joke
I had to come out I fell I felt like it
was my first day in prison I had to come
out swinging wait hold on and I don't
want to go back to the potty talk but
I had just gone in there to pee and I
said what the hell is that I mean that
you didn't you didn't use the bathroom
that was just what happened no I went in
to use the bathroom Okay and as I was
like
turning the light on or something I let
out a squeaker which was
hot
it was a fresh and ready CeCe Little
Caesar's Pizza
still doing over there
ah God damn it the goddamn big buck
Hunters on the fritz by the way [__]
thing we've had it a couple of months
not not even we just [__] bought this
goddamn thing I knew this was gonna
happen their gym now you gotta find a
Big Buck Hunter technician if you're out
there hit me up you don't think they're
gonna rip you off wow are they gonna see
me come I mean it's [__] they don't
even have underwear they're gonna
[__] bend me over
I think when it's I was thinking when
it's off because we're having this issue
a couple a couple weeks ago when it's
off we should put out of order sign on
it so nobody puts any quarters in there
okay I don't hate it I'm not the one
buying the out of order sign though
that's a you that's a you project I'll
just throw one up okay I thought he'd do
it
she's real artistic she is
um but that's neither here nor at air
gang we got a gosh darn Family episode
over here where uh we answer your
questions on a patreon when you sign up
for the patreon we will answer your
garbage questions on here and boy do we
have some hum dingers I'm always shocked
by the homies at the level of
trash that we have yet to over to unturn
you know what I mean comedic Geniuses
out there oh for sure some of the names
are fantastic but it's even like certain
rocks where I'm like oh and it's just
different that of like in my family I
didn't experience that like that wasn't
a thing or whatever you know what I mean
yeah this one's great this is for me and
ever had to wake your parents up for
work
that's man dude if your kid is waking
you up and you're going five more let me
get five more minutes yeah it's bad if
it's early
I don't know what's worse
I guess if it's like you're working the
graveyard shift
and they wake you up before they leave
for soccer practice like hey it's seven
o'clock get up I can kind of get that
but if it's in the if you're getting
woken up by your kid in the morning Yeah
by like you're like 13 year old son or
something the good news is Patty would
always uh she would trick us
she was she she got up crazy early my
dad got up late but she would carry get
up she'd freak out and get him up and
he'd get up and he'd rush out the door
but we never had to wake him up but she
would say she'd come into our room and
say it's 602 or whatever he had to be at
school at 6 15 or whatever yeah did she
be lying you you get it they always
that's the only get out of bed you look
at a clock it's 5 45 you're like God
[__] damn it yeah and you're doing a
mask and I get six more minutes or
whatever yeah no she's in there
screaming yeah there's too late the
apples and cinnamon oatmeal would be
cold
a rough wake up at that crib at my oh my
God tight house everybody [__]
screaming right the second they wake up
everybody freaking out and panicking bro
oh you don't know we were never late for
anything ever ever
we're 15 minutes early because once he
got up he would have anxiety come on we
gotta get going gotta get out of here I
gotta get out of here and she would just
her and my brother my brother be up
doing push-ups and [__] like that you're
just screaming with a mouthful of
Cheerios spraying cereal they're off my
back ah dude dying just looking for five
more minutes in Dreamland
yeah I was telling you asked me why I
you know why my alarm is done
yeah we had a good laugh at that his
alarm went off one time at like you know
I don't know 2 p.m or something sounds
like a sub going under dude it sounds
like there's a like Russia just launched
the nukes I'm like that which they could
and I'll be ready I'll tell you that I'm
like that's how you're starting your day
maybe that's why you're a little on edge
from time to time you wake it up in
[__] nuclear war
yeah that's how I get it yet looking for
a fallout shelter get her from Patty
yeah that's that ain't good Feels Like
Home
I wake up it's okay like Ray Liotta and
[__] good for you need a [__] you
need a handgun to your head when you
wake up right away just to feel
uh yeah that's trash that but that's a
[__] fantastic there's there's got to
be some sort of level of gauge to it as
well and I don't know what it is right
in if yeah if you've had to do it I
guess if they're working the later shift
that makes sense sure because their
hours are all [__] up that seems like
single dad [__] and like that's even
worse I feel no if you had like a
responsible
um young girl single dad and that's just
a plot they're Pretty in Pink but still
that that's how that would break down
yeah getting your dad out of bed I mean
I would be
I no actually I'm pretty good my dad
would have been screwed without Patty
yeah but he was also in the Navy so he
knew how to get himself up in the Navy
but he would he'd be in and out he from
the time he woke up to how quick he got
out of the door it was it was insane
yeah and he would do the thing where he
would pour a cup of coffee he'd take a
couple of sips put it under cold water
chug it a little bit chug a little bit
more and chug a little bit more until he
got the whole cup down out the door whoa
yeah he was a real one that's and if you
were going with him get in the car oh
yeah get in the car that's [__] up
okay but talk about that this plate
display
let's talk about cool metal posters that
hang up on your walls with just magnets
you don't got to put nails in you don't
got to do this you don't have frayed
edges all that stuff it's cool stuff
yeah do yourself a favor get over to
this plate grab yourself something they
have awesome licensing deals so you got
Marvel you got Star Wars you got cool
bands you got a little Seinfeld up on
the wall there
also you're not putting holes in the
wall you're not having a handyman come
over next thing you know you want that
deposit back don't you next thing you
know he's necking with your wife sure
click the link in our description to see
some of our favorites and get your ready
to hang piece of art save 22 if you buy
one or two and get 33 off when you buy
three or more baby they're giving away
the store 33 all let's go uh the
discount will automatically be applied
to your cart when you click our link
it's in the description check it out use
the code Garbage When you visit that's
g-a-r-b-a-g-e when you visit display.com
to get the discount that's display.com
code garbage or click the link in our
show notes do it baby Kip this is rocket
Money Baby rocket money this is rocket
money saving you money a lot of people
think that they have about eighty
dollars worth of subscriptions going
it's actually more like 200. rocket
money is a personal finance app that
finds it cancels your unwanted
subscription monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all all in
one place yeah it's fantastic uh rocket
money quickly and easily finds your
subscriptions and cancel the ones you no
longer want I didn't know for months I
did it I put it in I was subscribed to
dildo with a month club baby and I
wasn't getting a product either you know
what I mean it also helps you manage
your finances by categories categorizing
your expenses so you can see where that
paycheck is going the average user saves
up to 720 bucks a year who don't need
that at the end of the year it's a
couple packs of heaters and over three
million people have used rocket money to
get a handle on their budget stop
throwing away your money you bozos even
at homies can be bozos if you're
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
garbage that's rocketmoney.com garbage
rocket money one more time
rocketmoney.com garbage do it
your dad driving you to school was never
as fun as your mom driving oh you're
nuts I had the option really yeah
because my dad uh the custody was split
half and half he would stop and get you
if he had you had a couple of minutes
not even we were stopping oh really
you're late go in come out and get me if
they need and I would just go to the
door like I'm good yeah he didn't give a
f he was one of those guys I would call
him and even no I'm saying stop at like
a Wawa or something oh every day even if
we didn't have the time he don't care oh
really he don't care about me being five
minutes later he's going [__] school
would you do it that's what I love he
was just like yeah the rules
okay you're late they're gonna tell me
you're late I drop you off I don't give
a [__] would you do a breakfast at the
house and then grab like a bacon egg and
cheese no there was a time I mean there
was a no no
I don't think so maybe a cereal app at
the Cinnamon Toast Crunch appetizer
before I got my sizzling well I remember
sizzlies didn't hit all right so he
would pick me up
or because he was so he would go to work
I would set an alarm
at a or like my stepmom would wake me up
or whatever because I lived out of I
thought I couldn't take a bus to my
junior high or High School sure where
from where he lived right so but it was
like you know seven minutes or ten
minutes or so to live outside the school
district you're one of those well I was
in the school district but at another
school like I was registered at my mom's
and that yeah man it's [__] trash
dude then Wednesday Thursday usually
they Reserve those kind of slots for
athletes what do you mean like they they
looked the other way when they have a
good athlete that lives outside the
school district how I lived in the
school district
I was registered you have a bus route my
mom's I did right but not at your dad's
yeah yeah your dirt ball no I'm not
defending it but I'm just saying it's
not like that crazy when I was with my
dad he had to drive me to school okay I
wasn't like registered at his house okay
but people are gonna send me to another
school for two days a week talk about
[__] up
ah
that's like I mean what other option did
I have oh man they would have thought
you were a cop oh yeah [__] balding
already and stuff you got a light on you
only there on Tuesdays and Thursdays
what's up with that [__] big-headed
Bulb Guy only shows up every other day
asking me if I do weed
yo
smoke beasters shows up with another guy
drinking coffee every morning
you're a cool kid at one school and a
[__] nerd yeah Dad can I just go to
my school gotta go get beat up on
Wednesday and Thursdays
today uh no so he would leave for work
and pick me up at like whatever let's
say the standing time was 7 30. if I had
to be at school at eight right or
whatever they'll be like I'd be back
I'll be up and out the door already he'd
go to work go hit a job site go to the
office do whatever he had to do like
five o'clock
drop me off at Chi
the learning theme learning pipefitting
um I remember Patty drives me to
Community College that's [__] up dude
it's listen if you're really trying to
get your act together I respected it
which I wasn't that's what I'm saying
like if you had already crashed out or
something you were like you know what
[__] this I'm getting like I'm gonna
swallow my pride my mom's gonna take me
to [__] Community but if you're just
a [__] idiot and your mom's dropping
you off at school man if you can buy
beers and your mom's dropping you off at
school 13th grade dude dude her coming
home from work and picking me up and
driving me over there in rush hour
traffic honking the horn out front
you're fat ass is probably just jerking
off upstairs talking your little wiener
back in
ah
but she used to drop me off when I was
Landscaping too
over at this guy's uh cousin's house
where he kept the truck which wasn't the
most professional operation yeah there's
a there's a one on my street that's
where the key it's like his business and
that's where they keep it's like your
sister-in-law's house I think it might
even be his but it's like rag it's like
do for owning a landscaping company why
don't you get the [__] why don't you
get the trim routers have one of the
guys come in early sure it's a rough
that's where you make the cash though
when you keep it a small operation sure
don't mean you can't be [__] take
disease to the [__] zmo or over your
lawn looks like it was [__] bombed
out but so he would uh he'd come back
get me
that's crazy he would be at this point
he'd be on his looking for his second
hit of coffee okay right because he
would leave hit Wawa go to work come
back an hour too late or whatever it was
grab me we'd go hit Wawa again
I would get before sizzlies hit I would
do a plain bagel or a poppy seed bagel
with butter
they had them pre-wrapped right next to
the cash registers remember that there
was a row of cream cheese and a roll of
butt man a freshy good night
I would do a buttered bagel I wasn't
[__] with cream cheese at the time
dude gas station breakfast talk about a
sea student dude
I do a poppy seed Bagel if they had it
if not I'd sleep my first period but you
say falling asleep at first dude I was
nodding off before we got to school
[__] the insulin kid over here dude
that's not even it then I would [__]
do a straight uh either OJ or Wawa iced
tea
like not diet obviously just [__]
pure sugies and then I would do
sometimes in a winner I'd do a french
vanilla coffee
wait how old were you eight
French vanilla
remember they had the machine you'd
press the green button and it spit out
them it was like hot chocolate oh yeah
it was print it was French vanilla hot
chocolate I do I do a 16 ounce of that
and whatever I wouldn't take it in but I
would finish probably about half of it
I'd throw some ice cubes in there to
cool it off so I could get my [__]
just like your dad sure
so I could get some Shooters in there
yeah man then I would go with machine
technology for the first five years well
it's not stupid it was that was that was
like Mensa when they tried to do that
when they tried when when like gas
stations tried to like uptick to like
mochachinos and stuff like that dude it
was just hot chocolate I was there for
it it didn't matter dude I I felt like I
was European over there it didn't matter
how much caffeine was in those things
you would be so sleepy
sugar crash dude it doesn't matter uh so
then yeah I would do that and then
sometimes you'd have like an early lunch
or whatever so I'm [__] piggybacking
that at lunch at like 10 15 a.m sometime
so that was it he drove me to school
every day I stayed there always stopped
at Wawa
always got yeah and then even still when
I would drive it was just Pavlov's dog's
condition I would stop at Wawa get
brekkie head in couple of heaters never
did that never stopped in the morning
even when we drove never even really
occurred to me what was on the way
unless we were cut in school then we'd
go to Dells and get some eggs or go over
to Gene's Place yeah and load up Gene's
Place sounds like your buddy
please his mom was on the level
his dad played ball if you catch my
drift yeah uh yeah that was great
looking I mean that's why I'm a fat
piece of [__] because that was you know
I didn't know
that that was I mean I just learned that
that was kind of bad for you
probably seed bagels with butter oh man
sometimes they didn't have them out I'd
have to ask him oh
I remember somebody when I hit a bagel
for this latchkey kid remember we'll get
him out of my face and they're eating
like a [__] tin knocker
I remember my dad was like why are you
trying they're eating a hard-boiled egg
assault on it that was a [__] fat
piece of [__] I remember right that'd be
like when you try half a bagel I'm gonna
shut your [__] mouth and make good
with those Reds captain
oh God would you ever rip a heater in
the car with your dad not at eight
nine uh no it was after I think once we
once we started working together that
way sure like you defeated him in
hand-to-hand combat
he's gonna tried it
we had to do that leg wrestling where we
lock legs and who could ever flip each
other
real Roxboro [__] yeah
um no it wasn't until we started working
together that it was like sure let me
get one of them my stepdad
heaters well Dan my brother always
you know broke the seal sure so he would
be like you're too young to do it in
front of you know he's like you're
putting him in a bad situation if you
pull out a pack of heaters and light up
he's gotta have to say something sure
but
16.
with my stepdad he didn't care probably
18 19 with my dad and then from then on
when it was me my him and my brother
working it was like
bernieville every car every indoors out
it didn't matter we were [__] we were
the eater gang heater Plumbing
welcome to heater HVAC your house smell
like smoke well it will when we leave
instead of heating and air conditioning
it's heater and air conditioning that's
a shirt heater's an ace hippies heaters
and aircons conditioning
that's a new shirt Daddio
ripping heaters while I cool you down
how do we even start off with that oh
the dad going to work yeah waking your
dad up
uh speaking of heaters I was gonna say
real quick what I would have to do is
pop would still be in bed you know he he
he was able to get there a little bit
later I mean we'll be taking the bus
Patty be up curling her hair Good
Morning America was on
and uh we're in Catholic school we were
real little you had to go to him to get
your tie tied ah and he would just roll
out of bed and just sit on the side of
the bed and tie your tie with breath
that would burn your eyeballs the ties
searing up
just Crush you first thing in the
morning man you tried to keep that thing
tied for the rest of the week leave it
up pulling it out real slow doing it on
the doorknob like you know you're
[__]
uh
[Applause]
uh speaking of heaters let's see uh
this is from Eric B has your lip ever
started visually bleeding because you
kept the Sig there too long no but if
you keep it in there and you pull it out
sometimes that's what he's talking about
oh yeah draw the skin if you leave it in
there and it's a little too moist it
then draw the the cotton in it or with
the cotton ball absorbs all the the
liquid off your you know what I'm
talking about oh you're talking about
getting a Sig fuse oh you pull that out
let's do that in the winter boots in the
world they're gonna cover that up that's
bad that thing hurts yeah that's an old
that's a you'll learn that early and
then you can start to feel it before you
know you got to get out of Dodge oh man
that's a stinger you know what happened
to me the other day and we were talking
about this is this is Bernie logic which
we're getting off them by the way it's a
united front we're gonna do here
um
would you ever noticed I was talking to
Pat my buddy Pat was picking me up in
Philly out front of the hotel I was
staying at down near Center City and uh
I had my last Sig and I lit it backwards
sure and he's like it's always your last
Sig
and I was like I just thought about this
it's because that's the only that's
never in the pack
you take your last Zig out and you throw
the pack away and then the Sig is just
like in your ear or in your ear you know
what I mean you're fumbling with it
that's how it ends up backwards does
that make sense yeah like you're not
taking it right out of the pack I
haven't done that since I was a kid what
let us dig backwards yeah really not a
not a kid but it's been years no because
I was [__] up never tell you took a
drag of a snake backwards lit dude
talk about I wasn't this kid Justin's
house man it was like eating a
firecracker instant Alzheimer's right
there you know you know when you're
[__] up
and you're like this ain't right but
like the pain you have the feeling but
like the pain didn't really say I'm like
what is that like it was like I couldn't
process what was happening I looked down
I got the Cherry in my mouth like
[__] bozo
yeah Jamie up talk about a heater with
the gator uh this one's from Cut Toby's
hair which I agree have you ever tried
to kick down a door
I don't think I've ever been in the sip
it is a tray if you're kicking on a door
unless you're saving puppies or
something I let him kick down on me
that's worse yeah
by your parents or something parents
brothers or just Patty and SWAT gear
it's ourself
creep flashbang in a crucifix
growing holy water at you
um
yeah they're definitely parental
situation or my brother just messing
with me or me doing something to him the
move was you do something you get a
sneaker in there let me get behind a
locked door and then you run upstairs
and go behind your door and lock the
door what's he gonna do break the door
down he'll get what the it'll come
through cause we get those shitty little
on doors sure you go through those
things like butter yeah yeah they were
bad
um did you uh I remember my door being
off the hinge I was just gonna ask me I
think we talked about this years ago
yeah I don't think that ever happened to
me oh my door was off the hinges for
about a year because I because it was it
was busted like watching huh
hey looking's for free
uh uh my room used to be so dirt mine it
wouldn't infuriate my mother
infuriated
[Music]
the room in my dad's house I mean I used
to paint fat kid masterpieces up there
I'm talking
red Solo cups of iced tea that sometimes
I wouldn't finish they probably like my
third one or whatever a brand new fresh
bag of pizza Goldfish and I'm [__]
just I'm sitting I'm not even [__] I
was sitting on a blow up chair from like
a neon blow up chair
from Spencer's watching like WWF or
something just [__] I had a Britney
Spears poster hanging up looking at that
just in all my glory and uh jerking off
with pizza
and I would uh I feel like you'd stand
up and the chair would stick to your
body yeah you're not wrong
it was Scotch tape because I put a hole
in it by accident
so I had to use Scotch tastes preflex
God damn it
preflexial he got Bomb on Me
um yeah and I would leave cups in there
with a little bit of Wawa iced tea and
it would get mold in it after because
like yeah I remember my how he would
come in screaming at me
God damn petri dish get in the room
weren't allowed to eat in the room
scream that you caught up there with
something like that yeah jammed up not
on my mom's at my dad's it was more like
sure like when AJ went and lived with
Tony for a little while yeah you know I
mean you know what I mean I had a
stepmom but like she also couldn't
really act as like an authoritative
could you ever order out
as a kid
with the family there yes like I'm gonna
get a pizza whatever you guys are doing
you're doing yeah
oh my Richie Rich who's allowed to do
that that's crazy I'd be sent to boot
camp if I tried to pull that
you're nuts yeah
one of my cousins years ago didn't it
blew my brains out young what are my
young cousins
was like he ordered something
first of all ordering delivery in the
suburbs unless it was unless it was a
pizza but now with the Uber Eats and all
that stuff it's a little bit different
but it was something like that we just
did pizza yeah of course like pizza
cheese steak Chicken Holiday shout out
to you
ordered something
at like four o'clock I was like you you
we were talking about dinner he's like I
just ordered something I'm like what
wait who said that my little cousin whoa
crazy kids are these kids are cuckoo
these days yeah it's nuts yeah well we
also think back in the day delivery was
like an hour sure he had a tip you had
to grease the guy that was all new stuff
you know what I mean now it's old hat
yeah someone's doing it yeah everyone's
doing it
um yeah no we would get like the hey I'm
leaving I left you 20 for pizza that or
I'll call Angelo's they'll deliver it
the money's at the counter I go how much
am I tipping a guy and they go just give
them it all a guard you got it yeah
right what sure change that every time
we would go pick up an Angelo's my dad
would give me a 40 probably it was
probably 23. give me two twenties that
was that was like my income dude that
was The Vig [__] skimming give us
eight bucks I give him five back or
whatever
that's how I made my first million
game of Pac-man and sometimes people
like I get in the car like no change I
got nah I was like all right like Sharon
Stone and casino this guy
can't let's talk about Dave hey Dave
we've all been jammed up with unexpected
expenses you know what I mean things
come up late night ambulance ride from
the bar okay it's really no hard ground
Dave swinging for defenses Dave I'm on a
light bill or something like that Jesus
Christ how about car insurance he got us
on the run to Mexico what do you think
of this gang we've all been jammed up
that's the point with Dave you can get
straightened up for a little bit Dave is
a banking app that can help you get up
to 500 instantly with a little bit of
extra cash with Dave there's no interest
no late fees or no credit check yeah
that's more money to catch up on bills
and without having to wait for your next
paycheck tackle those expenses that have
been stressing you out millions of
people have already downloaded the Dave
app to get financial relief as they need
with extra cash so if you're in a pinch
and need some extra help download Dave
you'll be telling uh all your buddies
about your new best friend Dave uh
download the Dave app from the app store
right now or go to dave.com garbage
dave.com garbage sign up
for extra cash for an extra cash account
and get up to 500 instantly for terms
and conditions go to dave.com Legal
instant transfer fees apply banking
services provided by evolve Bank and
Trust member FDIC do it now back to the
show back to the show all right let's
see this one's from Jack Keating 10
homie never have one red shout out to
you yeah uh is it garbage to have bar
mats by the kitchen sink in your house
there's got to be an age level to that
because that's real wait the runners
yeah that said like Jack Daniels or
whatever at your house that's cool if
you're in your 20s that's pretty cool
that's pretty classy any house I lived
in a 20
that at least shows like he's talking
about family
I don't know what I'm yeah I'm the
Shakers next to get the Twizzler sticker
um remember playing with that thing when
you were a kid the thing that had the
spring on it that you put over the
Shaker I we didn't have one of those
until my brother we did he had a full
bar downstairs with that kind of stuff
yeah mixers and all that [__] oh no wild
we were
I thought we were a beer we were a beer
crew ah they just had it you know what I
mean they didn't really use it that much
yeah I don't remember that I thought
that stuff was like Space Age Technology
the spring it was like a slinky yeah
well that was all right uh no I don't I
mean I think if you're in your 20s sure
in bachelor pad you got some roommates
that's pretty cool sure I'm also a
[__] Dirtbag loser so I don't know
that seems pretty cool if I went over
someone's house but guys it would have
to be also clean like it would have to
be like hey we're doing this because we
use it a bunch back in the day in my 20s
if I was working at a restaurant I would
always steal a few uh bar bar Rags clean
ones oh yeah I mean bring them home and
use them yeah what are we doing man
those things are awesome that's yeah
that's of course
I think uh yeah that I mean bar matter
what what's the shot what do they call
where you drink all the stuff off the
bar mat at the end of the night oh bum
shots I've heard uh match shots
uh never in a million years for as
disgusting as I am hey I could never
that smell of rubber and what the [__]
yeah I couldn't do it great gray snail
the Jersey Turnpike all right sweaty
bartender
okay I mean that's crazy
that's absolutely crazy
yeah I couldn't do it
oh God there's no point there's no what
is it like I'm just crazy that kind of
thing it's I got a dollar I'm trying to
get [__] up it doesn't it's mostly
mixer and [__] like that I don't know no
you know the world's sloppiest bartender
no one's missing that much booze if
they're moving units in there sure
that's all sour mix maraschino cherry
juice which hey what's wrong with that I
love a maraschino cherry I know you do
you tell me I don't know every 48 Hours
big Maraschino guy
um put a little sword in it you know you
know what was big I want to say what was
the name of that place it was like a
restaurant a lot this happened a lot in
the suburbs in the early 2000s when I
was in college
2006 2007 there was a lot of restaurants
that I guess we're in like the family
for a while right you know Angelo's
pizza or whatever you know the Fresco's
Pizza sure
they would [__] they all got muscled
out no they had come across some money
the LA something was paid off something
or they like took out an equity loan
against the business or something and
they all got the place next door too and
turned that into like a bar
loungy type thing yeah and every once a
week they would do this place has dollar
beers that place has two dollar Piers
it's Quizzo here so as a dirt bag in the
city we would go or in the in the burbs
was home from the city during the summer
it was like Thursdays with Kenny's on
Street Road you go there five dollar
cover dollar Miller lights all night
long then you hit a wild weasel after
that get yourself a french vanilla
cappuccino pizza place in our hometown
tried to like they did that same thing
yeah they all did it they put in like
this nice bar
yeah who the [__] hanging out in a
pizza place like that we would I mean
because it was dollar beers you're in
The Burbs you got nowhere else to go
you're like oh let's go get [__] up a
couple years ago this place did it cut
down you go in to pick up I'm there I
that was great for us though that there
was the bowling alley we did because
they had dollar games and I think
quarter or dollar pitchers they're
certainly work in the system good for
you yeah well we were [__] broke you
know what I mean I thought it was more
of the comment of when the pizza place
when the second generation it was very
second generation second generation
small restaurant they try to they expand
the one room doesn't look like the
original one yeah they put like
additional seating or like try to class
it up a little bit start doing
appetizers and stuff like that stop what
are you doing I don't know I didn't mind
it yeah cheap beers good slices what
more do you need it never stayed it
never kept up he had one good waitress
for a little while and all sudden it
went downhill I remember one time in
this place where we used to skate shout
out to Villa tires it was like the dirt
bag headquarters if you were a [__]
pretty shitty kid you you were hanging
out there that's where all that's where
you skated that's where people bought
you smoked strip mall kind of like a
yeah similar but not it was like a
little there was one over here one over
here but uh it was a shopping center a
shopping center
in front of a townhouse or apartment
community that's specifically what this
was yikes the whole neighborhood was
called Village tires and so it was
disappeared in a place like that that is
a bad news and we hung out there that's
how we get smokes that's where we buy
weed that's where people get you know
the ice cream guy would buy his booze or
whatever feel the lights coming on in
the summer yeah I can feel it you look
over the the dark line of the trees and
you can see a little bit of the blue in
the sky I'm cranking a Marlboro Menthol
trying to do a kickflip it was a whole
if you see a bat or two streaking across
the sky a lot of we had a lot of wife
beaters on you know what I mean a lot of
fitted hats we were really [__]
really thought we were doing it but why
did I bring that oh they they put in a
nightclub in there the pizza place
expanded bought what used to be a
Mexican restaurant that they were moving
drugs out of and turned it into like a
nightclub where you could buy bottles
I'm like there's a guy smoking crack
over here who's what the hell wants to
buy a bottle here did I go and hang out
a couple two three times and check the
scene try to get laid you can't get
bottles and garlic knots
in the same place no they were separate
it was a separate entity still yeah you
can smell the garlic over there it was
uh that's a tough look they made trying
to make it like a steakhouse if I recall
that night it was a it was a club that's
the place where the music is blasting
and there's nobody in there instead of
bottles they're just giving you plastic
handles yeah here you go there's a
pop-off and [__] I remember hanging two
three times just in water no ice it was
it was at that time was a lot of
flashing lights in there and you're just
like we're hanging out at Black Bull
that's what it was called Black Bull and
I think there was another one like Black
Label there was multiple that's when
like put a name some flashy lights and
expensive Kettle One drinks and I'm in
you know what I mean I'm in there
striking out in this dirty dirty pair of
jeans no underwear on
a little bit of Pinnacle Whipped Cream
to get going
yeah man it was uh
time to be alive huh yeah that was
something else
I'm not 100 sure but that might be
making like a I don't know if it's a
comeback or not what but uh a few a few
a lot of Affliction shirts it was that
time no a few of my cousins that are of
age they're like 21 22 23.
maybe 21-22 they're they were some one
of them was mentioning about uh Pinnacle
Whipped Cream and like cotton candy
those flavored vodkas I think at that
age that's what it is even still yeah I
mean it's flavored vodka it's for
children sure you know what I mean I
figured now they'd be on like the white
Claws and all that [__] yeah sure but
that's probably like the beer instead of
drinking beers or drinking white calls
if they're trying to get you know
tearing up well Luke's that age she
doesn't he doesn't partake in that stuff
what Pinnacle yeah he probably does
really and Prime in college I'm sure he
was drinking or marshmallow whatever we
were an absolute Crew That's What
absolute Citron and we would have my
dude looking back that was [__]
classy but what we would do absolute
never got into the the like cotton candy
and all that stuff it was Citron then it
was Tangerine maybe uh current which I
don't know what that was but
give me some
I still don't know what it is it's a
clove or something nah it's kind of it's
like a berry or something yeah one some
one did a sweet tea vodka that was
incredible listen do you want to hear
how big of a [__] alcoholics my
family is we use that
to mix with vodka that's how we make
vodka iced teas in the summer down the
shore and Sea Isle and wildwood it's
sweet tea it's called like Sweetbriar or
Bry or something it's the pre-mix sweet
tea vodka and then we dump vodka in
there
couple lemons maybe some [__] Sprite
or something that and transfusions are
big you know transfusions no you would
love transfusions you know what Patty
it's a golf drink which I didn't know
Patty used to be big into the uh The
margaritas the frozen margaritas and the
bucket
where you just let that thaw out like an
ice cream like an ice cream cake for a
couple of minutes and then started
scooping on happiness uh blow your hair
a transfusion they're great we do them
down the shore summer on the beach off
the beach hey under some some
transfusions that's grape juice
uh ginger ale
wait what is it what is the transfusion
made of vodka ginger ale concord grape
juice and lime juice it's [__]
fantastic I know you're related to Lil
Wayne sipping
right got that purple on me dog oh it's
great it's a golf drink I just learned
this weekend actually wait what's in it
grape juice ginger ale vodka ginger ale
or Sprite or whatever you just need some
sugar Fizz vodka ginger ale uh concord
grape juice and lime juice a big conquer
great it's [__] great Welcher's grape
juice Firefly sweet tea vodka that
sounds right okay dude that's 35 ABV
that's like putting vodka into
Jagermeister man I remember I didn't
think anything of it and my my a family
friend our buddy Nikki came over and he
was like a couple glasses out of her
bull nuts be out there on the Dance
Floor
[Laughter]
my low-rise panties
um my buddy Nikki came over it was like
Fourth of July and we are ossified drunk
and he's like you're not supposed to mix
that with vodka there's vodka in there
and we were my uncle John was like
somebody threw him out of window
yeah you guys you guys are the only ones
that I know that makes vodka with we're
heavy boozers which I love by the way
that's all right it is what it is
oh God all right let's see here uh this
one's from Isaiah shout out to you never
had one red is it garbage or toasted
bagel on an open flame of a gas stove
because you don't own a toaster
buddy I've been there two three hundred
times 15 years ago
20 years ago I would have said yeah
but that's kind of that they do it with
the tortillas and stuff oh that was a
[__] game changer throw it on an open
flame realize that that that's what you
could do
man that Peta forget about it you take a
couple of those net carb uh tortillas
a couple of seconds on each side don't
go crazy with the flame you turn your
back you'll set up the whole kitchen you
got to keep it real low toast them up a
little bit then get a little Char I
don't mind it man that's what we're
supposed to be doing cooking on over
Open Flame yeah not in your [__]
studio apartment setting the [__]
smoke alarm off we've made s'mores in
there that's crazy trashy is it
yeah I don't think so you all the gas
stove not an electric stove I mean yeah
you'd be you'd be there all week
uh yeah no it's still trashy I'm not
saying it's not a good time and I don't
like a s'more who don't like a s'more
from time to time sure but that's that's
not how David that's not how they write
them in the [__] take the kids away
yeah yeah that's real I gotta wake Dad
up in 20 minutes for work type [__] you
pass the judge me drinking vodka and
vodka
put a shot of vodka
um all right let's see
um we've talked about this one this is
from knockoff Bagel Bites never with
soda though
when you buy a 12 pack of certainly put
it in the fridge do you take it out or
do you just put it in the fridge we're a
big fridge everything goes in the fridge
I was just down on my mom same thing you
open it up there's a [__] a 12 pack
of Coke grip from the Middle where the
handle was so you can grab the coke out
of there it's not like you don't we
don't use not lined up like in cribs
yeah yeah
um
I'll say this
now in the modern era of the Foley of
the Foley house
the soda's not in the fridge
same with us really she gets like a 12
pack of like
8.9 ounce Pepsi caffeine free diet Pepsi
and that'll be in the closet in the
front where the coats are if you want a
Pepsi grab one and you got to get a
thing of ice which it goes through the
ice like butter yeah because it's
[__] it's about 88 degrees Yeah I
hate that she's real wishy-washy over
there these days the water you know the
bottles of water you know how long it's
been sitting in the sun room it's just
all micro plastics it's real it's real
kooky man it's real kooky I rolled the
dice on some eggs at my mom's the other
day that weren't in a container they
were just like in the bin
uh it was the last week we were talking
we were talking a lot of hard feelings
about uh when I went to uh my niece's
lacrosse game and Patty was doing the
flyers for the lacrosse sure I don't
know if I told you somebody gave my
niece a dozen eggs to give to my mom
what are they doing now what are they on
the barter system well they all people
are starting to have chickens
now that's a broad statement and now
there's two people your mom knows that
have chickens so the other one and she
puts the date on them the lady told her
like three months you can have them
not at my breakfast table I'll tell you
that right now but I better not do that
European [__] where they keep them on
the Shelf I'll be over at Jean's place
no she puts them in the fridge she's not
crazy I don't think you can what once
there's well that's a that's like a
that's a mass farming thing they're
sprayed with something no I know I know
but if there are those people in
spraying them I don't know if they can
go in the fridge I think that's like a
bunch of chicken start running around
coming out of the fridge
I don't know it was the loudest thing I
ever seen feathers in your eyes a little
kid walks over with a dozen eggs in like
uh in like a in a not an egg container
I'm like what the [__] what are you
doing [__] Jordan box
[Laughter]
sneaker bugs
yeah yeah that's a tough look I'm dude
my wife does and I told you she gets
meat from the Amish people I'm like I'm
not meeting a guy in a van to get meat
I'm getting it from the [__] store
that's or butcherbox.com that's all I'm
doing
I'm not getting this [__] you're
giving me this I'm doing this for you
now I'll go to the store if it ain't got
a barcode I ain't buying it B and B
should get into the egg game that'd be
nice I think you can ship eggs like that
no
I don't know this kid's walking around
lacrosse field with him what are you
talking about sure they put him in the
car we went and had lunch brought him
back to the house I got the hell out of
there
no I'm not doing a cup of coffee for me
uh uh all right let's see this one's
from Jake Zee uh 10 shareholder never
had one red is it garbage to try to heat
your above ground pool by using a metal
trash can with a bonfire in it the trash
can floats around the pool with help of
some 2x4 stabilizers PS it did not work
as expected yikes
in theory that would be fun a nice
summer night fire water a little fire
and ice type thing you got cooking if it
wouldn't be able to heat it why because
it's it's too much water to try and heat
with just one trash can full of fire I
mean what do you think a heater is doing
though it's putting out more BTUs than
than a trash can isn't the right word I
think it is I think that's air
conditioning no the BTUs on a heater
yeah you might be right I've only ever
heard it it's a British thermal unit
which could be hot or cold right yeah
it's a is a measure of heat there you go
ah there you go
um
plus here's the thing dude a fire burns
at what 212 degrees a [__] huge
swimming pool an above ground pool it's
not that big that's what I'm saying
you'd need like four or five trash cans
to eat that you're nuts
you're crazy I'm an above ground pool
guy
Mr saltwater pool or ozone pool whatever
you're swimming in I don't have a pool
Your Country Club
along the country club I don't belong to
a country club I don't have a bowl we
had a pool growing up and I'm probably
it's probably backfilled at this and let
me say this what here's the difference
if you're an above ground pool person
be an above ground pool person if you're
an in-ground pool person be that way
have the heated pool with the stone
waterfall coming out of the out of the
uh out of the the jacuzzi
above ground pool people
we want it cold
because we can't afford the in-ground
pool with the heat so we lie to
ourselves and we say oh we like it cold
we like to it's refreshing in the summer
which it is at night gets a little
that's what I'm saying a little [__]
heater wouldn't kill you that's what I'm
saying you raise that up eight eight
degrees that's a party you're you're
cutting yourself off despite your nose
you get used to it after a couple of
minutes
[Laughter]
what are we doing here get the chickens
from next door and eating a pool myself
let's do it
uh all right let's see this one's from
Robert Redford's penis right uh are you
garbage If instead of throwing out your
old mattress you rip it up and use it as
packing material crazy
how much are you sending that would have
to be in your apartment for [__]
man I mean
a hundred years
you have to work at a shipping Depot or
something like that you know the stuff
that used to be in a box spring the
springs and it was like this white stuff
not really oh man
I've hauled out a couple of real old box
springs yikes the white stuff it was
like white like lining or velvet it was
kind of like felty I know exactly what
you're talking about but it was like
turned into like popcorn it looked like
asbestos yeah maybe yikes
um yeah that's you should be doing that
that's not I mean if you work
if you own a shipping company that might
make sense to me if you're like yeah
we're just gonna fill out this box let's
we use newspaper or [__] packing
peanuts or [__] whatever sorry your
package smells like 10 years
this guy's bunker
what do you want from me I sent you
something in the mail
it's a little piece of me
yeah get out of here with that oh God
get out of here
um
all right let's see there's some
Sergeant hangs low Five Dollar Tree show
me never have one red as a carbs if the
person in front of you pays for your
food at the drive-through and you don't
pay for the person behind you I'm all
jammed up
ah yeah dude breaking a pay a forward
line is a tough I've never experienced
anything like that have you been in
something like that I think so so the
first person would have to pay for their
food and the person behind them yeah Pay
It Forward type thing huh I've never
been involved in something like that I
would love to be in on that yeah it's
because I see you in the rear view
putting that bill
damn rents dude I got kids in school
that fat ass is on his own
what do you get that fat [__]
back there what do you get
three apple pies uh-uh this accident has
changed to five different people
um yeah I I think I paid it Forward yeah
I'd be like but it's also like if you
have it you have it you're willing to
pay you're in line ordered willing to
pay for yours
yeah who gives a [__] who give you're
still out you're eight bucks or whatever
yeah whatever it is yeah and true unless
you know you see the Moon behind you
I'm just smiling I think the only time I
would not pay it forward obviously if I
was jammed up like this gentleman but
but you would eat the free food if
nobody was behind me oh come on hey
buddy I don't know
you pull out of the line go over the
curb
ha I think that would be the only time I
would do it you know what happened to me
this morning uh I told you that my uh
my one uh outdoor furniture blew off and
fell into the construction site next
door I had to go down there get a beat
up by some construction workers
real men it looks a lot different
when you get down there the mud's about
four inches thick as it was raining I
was down there in my Crocs and shorts
but I walked in there I was like hey man
my uh what you want to call it blue blue
over you guys fence can I can I grab it
and the kid the kid was like yeah I'll
go get it you can't come back you know
what I mean there was [__] everywhere in
[__] Crocs that's a job you know
that's not an ocean groups can't be have
your Piggly wigglys out on a goddamn
construction site start sinking in oh
man wait dude first of all hold on do
you ever see that fat lady that gets
stuck in the foam pit
now they have them at like the
trampoline park she goes through like a
dart in and just like oh this is so fun
then it cuts to her dude she can they
have like 15 people pulling because she
doesn't have the upper body strength to
pull herself out oh that would be me
okay I'd go straight to the bottom dude
they're trying to dig her out I'm like
dude that's something I've never done
what I've never been in a ball pit I
missed it I missed it as a kid I never
got the opportunity to go into a ball
pit I always wanted to he missed it I we
I never I never got to do it and it kind
of didn't start getting some steam that
were on my radar until I was getting
older maybe like 11 12 13. what year
were you born
1976. Eric McMillan created the first
ball pit in
1976. wow yeah really Captain kids in
San Diego yeah McDonald's had them for a
little while
yeah
never got to jump into a ball pit they
say there's like a crazy amount of poop
in there I'm sure like it's like a you
know worse in my underwear
I'm sure you gotta take that out by the
way sure I'm sure the uh
oh look I'll handle it actually let me
I'm like Fast Eddie
um
what was I saying poop and ball pits go
pooping ball pits I always wanted to do
it not pooping a ball pit I always
wanted to I was gonna take a dookie in
it yeah never got a chance really yeah
there ain't were a good time I dude it
seemed like it was the greatest thing
ever it wasn't it wasn't I was also
scared of him too that I would drowned
in it for some reason or not be able to
get out
I assume there was some way I could get
smothered in there they were like kind
of tough you know if they were deep
enough to get your foot some older kid
grab you pull you in you see that
jackass they put like anacondas in there
[__] they were biting them and [__]
[__] that but this kid walked over got
the got the uh thing for me and brought
it back tried to hit him with a dub
no I can't come on brother I listen it's
me gave him the whole song and dance
wouldn't take it he's like not have a
song and dance I just really pushed
Foley I'm a singer actor and comedian
you want a picture hey buddy let me
print this out inside you're trying to
give him a sign that shot Hey sir get
your fat ass out of here before you get
hurt it's obviously in the service
industry that guy probably makes [__]
more than you I know but it was just
nice of him to do that
he could have been a dick he could they
could have not gave it to me I know but
that's weird to tip someone not in a
service industry to me it's kind of
disrespectful honestly really you think
a little bit huh yeah like all here you
need like ah here you go no I don't know
what I'm saying people can take is like
what if someone tried to tip you I'm
just saying you know what I mean you're
like I don't [__] work for like after
show someone's like oh here if it was
something like that
no if it was if it was something like
that I would say I would do this I would
have done the same thing that he did but
I was just shocked that he did it he's a
good kid
yeah but you haven't seen you would have
done the same thing and I was I'm also
older than him he was probably like in
his early 20s
sure working as a foreign
thing but I think age
sometimes balances that out
you know what I mean I'm 47. sounds like
you could play 32. thank you it's not
like I gave it to like a thousand pounds
I think it gave it to like a 56 year old
man I know I'm just saying but I mean
like yeah I don't know anyway the point
of the story was that he was he was a
good guy
yeah
great that's all I got all right we got
to wrap it up though gang that's it yeah
buddy we already we're well over an hour
here what do we got what do you got for
them out there uh
uh obviously we have Columbus and
Cleveland coming up those tickets are
there's maybe about 20 30 tickets left
to each show for that get those while
you still can August 11th Late Show
added at the Vogel theater tickets are
moving that's about halfway sold out the
second show that is for sure gonna
[__] sell out because I want to come
grab those tickets let's [__] hang
it's gonna be a party we did one last
year sold it out we're selling out to
this year I'm calling it now let's do it
baby also obviously like the big man
said merch is available at all you
garbage.com we have Zippo Zippo style
lighters and t-shirts check them out
gang we love you thank you for the
support love you gang we'll see you next
week peace